so let's say you have a website and you
also built an app for a more seamless
experience on mobile as people share and
follow web links to your content on
Android they will normally see the speed
bump that we call it disambiguation
dialog it's shown when the user has many
apps on your device which can handle the
same type of link in this case one
containing your domain and the URL but
wouldn't it be great if users who follow
a link to a website that you own get
sent directly to your app my name is
Wojtek caliche ski and I'll show you how
app links a new feature in android
marshmallow lets you do just that now
there are two conditions an app needs to
meet in order to get rid of the
disambiguation dialog for good one it
has to be configured to handle urls
pointing to your website and two you
must be able to prove that he control
the domain under which your site is
hosted let me show you how to do it
first look at your Android manifest file
and make sure that you have at least one
activity with an intent filter that
matches the following for the data
element it uses an HTTP or HTTPS scheme
with your domain as the host it also
needs to have a view action and a
browsable category if you've implemented
deep linking in your app before you
might notice that you have that part
configured already there's one more
detail you need for enabling app things
though and that's the new auto verify
attribute so make sure you add this as
well this will tell the system to kick
off domain verification when your app is
installed let me walk you through it
last step now in order to associate your
site with your app you will need to put
a digital asset links JSON file on this
exact path under your website's root
directory the format of the file is
pretty straightforward you can just copy
the sample from our documentation and
replace the two highlighted values with
your apps package name and the
fingerprint of your signing certificate
you should leave the other fields
exactly as shown here be careful if
you're using a different certificate or
package name for your debug build or you
will run into problems later also make
sure the file you create is accessible
over HTTPS as that's the only way
Android will be able to successfully
verify the connection now how do you
test if everything is working properly
just
stole your app on the device like you
normally would using ADB Android studio
or any other method then tap on the link
to your website from any app or you can
issue a command through ADB that will
start the appropriate intent observe
what happens next if you set up both
parts the intent filters and the JSON
file correctly your app should launch
immediately if you do see a
disambiguation dialog that means the
package installer wasn't able to verify
your domain you can use the digital
asset links tool to see if your JSON
file is reachable and parsed correctly
with these simple steps you can make
life easier for your users so go and
implement app links now or check out the
other great features that we're
introducing an Android marshmallow
thanks for watching